when I was eight years old we lived in
Minnesota really yeah Edina Minnesota
really because you know what else
happened up there yeah Highway to Heaven
bro I get it dude
and I lived in Edina Minnesota Dover
Drive was my street and I remember I
didn't have a lot of friends
so one day I went I was like eight years
old and I go Mommy Daddy
could I have a pet
and they go oh what kind you know I go a
cat
so they got my cat a kitten and I
remember that summer um I'll kind of get
emotionally even thinking about it
I named him Tom because it's like I
didn't know anything else Tom and Jerry
was a thing back then so it was good
yeah so I named Tom and I remember being
in the garage because that he wouldn't
be letting the house we kind of had like
a little pen in the garage and I would
play with him all day long
for weeks
and then one day I left I came home and
Tom was gone I was freaking out
and my dad looked at me goes He no
longer here
I go what happened I put a pound
no and I go why mommy allergic
and then I started crying and they go
stop crying
and then they left the garage and I
remember sitting there tears there's no
voice like you know no compromise no how
do you feel your men no one reason why
no reason why there's no there's I
there's no voice right and I just had to
take it
I was powerless right and I just
um that's like my upbringing in a
nutshell like I just felt like no one
heard me and so that's why I learned to
act out
I learned to like you know be funny and
um
do [ __ ] but it's like that's why I have
seven animals now wow I mean because
it's like I I love you know I love
animals so much and it's like I don't
know I just I'm just compensating for
that you know I mean I don't know what
happened to that kid
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one